hey this is um this i think this is
exciting
the david pakman show is hiring we have
a small team
and we very rarely have open positions i
get emails all the time from people
wanting to
uh intern or work part-time or offering
their services in different ways and we
essentially are almost never hiring
we are uh is it lucky blast fortunate
that um many of our our employees stay a
really long time
and we have a position that is available
and i want to tell you about it in case
you want to apply or you know somebody
that might want to apply
i will tell you at the end of this
segment how to express interest
and if you do anything outside of what
i'm saying to express interest we're
unfortunately gonna have to ignore it
because
we have to set some guidelines and and
create some structure here
so this is a position that is remote you
can be anywhere for this position
but that being said we mostly are
working on east eastern u.s
time zone all right this is a
multi-disciplinary position
that includes social media and writing
it includes video editing it includes
publishing of content and yes it
includes some
sales no getting no no cold calling
people
on the phone but yes interacting with
possible advertisers and brands via
email
so i think the easiest way to explain
this position to be would be to tell you
kind of like what a typical day would
look like
the typical day would start with um
making a bunch of social media content
and scheduling posts maybe for that day
maybe for the weekend
this includes to our instagram this
includes
uh twitter this includes facebook tiktok
etc and other platforms we're going to
expand to so first piece of it would be
working with the team to figure out what
did well yesterday on youtube
let's amplify some of that stuff what
funny memes do we have on reddit etc
alright that's piece one of the day
second part of the day we are looking
very strongly
at launching a second youtube channel we
have so much live stream content right
now
that there's lots of things that happen
on live streams that would be very
clipable
as individual clips but our main youtube
channel is essentially full
with the clips from the podcast and
interviews and this type of thing
so the ideal person would be able to
understanding the culture of the show
and what's interesting and what's funny
go through the previous day's live
stream and pick out
a handful of moments either live calls
or reviews of clips or whatever
the case may be that would be good
stand-alone clips for this
second youtube channel working under the
tutelage of producer pat
cutting these titling them understanding
metadata thumbnails click bait titles
obviously you know
we will teach you clickbait titles and
managing this potential
second youtube channel very good that's
part two so we've got social media
and this new second channel we are
thinking of part three
is working under the tutelage of
producer
and business development uh mastermind
noah to um
do some sales outreach and this inc some
people may know this some people may not
we do ad sales not just for the david
pakman show but also for other shows we
are almost in a sense an ad
agency and we want to expand that so
working under the tutelage of noah
you would learn how do we grow our list
of
shows on which we place sponsors
how do we make initial contact with
sponsors and hopefully you would get to
the point
of negotiating your own deals as well
that would be part three of the job
um and then uh part uh well i guess
those are the three main parts and then
the other thing would be uh also
learning the technical production of the
show
how is the show carried out on a daily
basis
uh such that if we were to have
um an illness like for example when i
had my appendectomy
well pat pat filled in for me but but
you wouldn't be expected to fill in for
me
but what if pat was out what if we had
to you know whatever you would
essentially learn to be a
backup producer for the show as well so
this for the right person
would be full time it also may start as
part time
and that would be absolutely fine it
would eventually be a full-time job with
benefits
the key things are less about technical
know-how
we've learned that we can really teach
people all of the tech skills
what we can't teach is being a really
good writer and written communicator
we can't teach uh go get em
type attitude and and people being uh
go-getters
we can't necessarily teach you know
working well in a fast-paced environment
working on four or five different things
each day so those are really the big
things
we are setting a requirement that you
either have to have a college degree
already
or be in your last semester right now
and that is
for a number of different reasons and to
reduce certain certain complications
if you want to apply we have a formal
job description that i can send
you can inquire with a letter of
interest and resume
or without one just asking for the
position description
the only way to send inquiries about
this job is
info davidpakman.com and please make the
subject of your email
job opening okay in the email
please confirm that you either have a
college degree or in your last
semester tell me a little bit about
meeting those requirements
of being a good written communicator
working well in teams working well in a
fast-paced environment et cetera
and um we are going to we we anticipate
i mentioned this on the stream yesterday
we're already getting a lot of interest
so we anticipate a lot of interest and
uh it's very very exciting
the team is growing we are growing
content we are growing a lot of
different things all right
i've said way too much i've gone on for
a long time but hopefully that gives you
a sense of what's going on and
info davidpakman.com is the one and only
place to inquire
no voicemails no visits to producer
pat's apartment
none of that all right